[Music]
now at five governor steve sisselak has
tested positive for covid19 that
announcement coming into our newsroom
about an hour ago i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez the governor says he
underwent routine testing today
and a rapid test did give him that
positive result our vanessa murphy is
following the story and has more details
for us tonight vanessa
governor siselek is currently in
quarantine at the governor's mansion
up north he says he does not currently
have covid19 symptoms but
he did previously feel fatigued he
thought he was just tired
he has a busy schedule now he gets
tested
at least once a week though his last two
tests on november 6th and november 2nd
came back
negative the latest test with the
positive results as you mentioned is a
rapid test
he's still waiting for the results of a
pcr test which does not provide
immediate results now because of the
positive test the governor will be
checking in with a physician regularly
a spokeswoman says his wife tested
negative for covid19
the governor personally called other
close contacts at this time
staff from the governor's office will
also be in quarantine
earlier this week sisilak attended a
ribbon cutting and also he held a press
conference
about a spike in covid 19 cases
in our state now the governor made a
post on facebook he says he's using this
as an opportunity to remind nevadans to
stay home
and he referred to the numbers in nevada
the more than
1800 new cases identified in nevada
yesterday
and he says cases are growing at a rate
of 1.3 percent
or about 1400 new cases
per day now it appears the governor is
one of these new cases
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now